oh my God I I am in love with your suit
that's my favorite color Yes Green's
your favorite color yes oh mine's red
and blue it is very American of you yes
thank you red and blue USA yeah um I I
used to love you until you said the
Cowboys were going to win and then look
what happened I don't understand
everybody was saying that we were going
to look we say it every year I get it
but like but I really did think like we
had all the players it was all there I
know I I did that pick for you too I you
look here's the thing I yelled so
hardcore I I became that crazy fan watch
I got really into football this season
I'm like into fantasy football do you
have you ever played fantasy as well I
never played fantasy football ever I
know all about fantasy football you
don't think about that like as a as a
football player you were like man what
if these people were all combined on one
team well you kind of had that cuz yeah
I actually knew how it worked and like
throughout the season when I was playing
I always made sure I was like okay if I
can score touchdown there's like 2
minutes left in the fourth quarter we're
already winning by like three touchdowns
but if I can somehow sneak another
touchdown in for my fantasy owners
they're going to love me that's what we
say at home just walking in and then you
start getting angry at the other players
that you don't have but it's so fun
anyway does it anger you that fans we
use the word we like we're like we lost
and like we didn't do anything like does
it you know what I'm saying actually no
it doesn't anger me at all because
without the fans we wouldn't have the
NFL we wouldn't have
so it's it's a collectivist so we make
sense okay cuz I feel insane at the end
my daughter is like why do you keep
saying we and I'm like I used to be you
I know but now I'm them anyway what's
like one of your favorite because you
have so many great Super Bowl moments
like what's what's one of your favorite
uh my favorite Super Bowl moment is when
I won my first Super Bowl I got into the
Super Bowl Club that's what it's all
about you just want to get into that
club and uh we beat the Seattle Seahawks
in 2015 they were going to be they were
trying to be repeat Champions which
hasn't been done in quite some time it
might be done this year for the first
time since the Patriots did it what 0304
but that that game that we played was
just spectacular Patriots you mean
Chiefs right or no patri no no the
Patriots were the last one to go back to
back I think it was 03 Oh I thought you
meant who's going this year I was like
the Chiefs win this year again they're
the first team to go back to back in
Super Bowl wins since the Patriots I
think 0304 right around those years but
uh that Super Bowl vers Seattle Malcolm
Butler with that game ceiling
interception to win the game let me tell
you is the most fabulous game of all
time and one of the best Super Bowls
ever too that's the thing about football
you never know yes yeah that's why
there's a movie called Any Given Sunday
I love that soundtrack oh miss y has a
good song on that of course I went
musical with it whatever um so wait so
Super Bowl's in Vegas I'm going to be
there um you're going to be there
obviously so like are are you excited
are you a Vegas guy uh I'm a Vegas guy
in a way and I look at Vegas totally
different than the way I looked at Vegas
when I was 22 years 23 years old you
remember it now yes I I didn't remember
it really back then when I was uh that
age but Vegas I used to just think was a
complete party 247 you have to go there
you're drinking right when you get off
the plane you're drinking going back on
the plane when you're leaving and you're
thinking all about what you just did the
last 24 hours or 48 hours there yeah
recall it but uh I don't look at Vegas
like that anymore you know I'm a little
bit more older I I like to go there now
I like to go to shows I like to go to
concerts um I just like to enjoy the
whole atmosphere of what Vegas has to
offer and not just go there and just
start raging right
away those are for 20-year-olds that
have that the ability to wake up the
next day and not feel like death yes
yeah yeah yeah those 20y old days think
we did feel like deatha afterwards we
just kept going back it's like pregnancy
why why do we do it again I don't know I
have to say it has to be very different
from obviously playing the actual game
to then being an analyst like becoming
that and like talking about like was
that hard uh uh a little bit because you
know I love to be put on the spot and
fourth and goal you know with on on the
5 yard line I'm used to that situation I
love that situation when my numberers
called I have to go up and make a play
but now I was using my body and my mind
in a physical way and now I'm doing it
more in a mental way so we're on every
Sunday before the games and now it's
like fourth and goal but I'm doing it
mentally yeah and I got to produce live
right on that spot right at the moment
mentally not phally anymore so it's a
little bit of a different transformation
but I love it because I get to offer my
unique perspective to the game of
football as well we love it it's just so
much fun doing it yeah I said
we that is a that that does work we
athletes do many um many of the same
things when they retire grank and his
former teammate Julian Edelman recently
had some fun with that so let's see it
we're retired athletes we're going to
get jobs on TV we're retired athletes
we're going to tease a comeback we're
retired athletes we're going to watch
our old highlights we're retired
athletes we're going to start a
podcast this should have been an SNL SK
it's so funny they should do that with
musicians as well we're retired athletes
you go on the Kelly Clarks show very
good time good time so wait whose idea
was that are you into social media uh a
little bit okay yeah social media is
cool you know you got to use it for the
right reasons but I was at Julian
alman's house he has a great podcast
called names with games yeah and uh we
just did his podcast and he has his
whole social media team there and then
they showed me this new trend on Tik Tok
and that was the new trend and they were
like we're going to do it as retired
athletes and it was such a great idea
and it came out so good I know I was
telling you in the break I was like that
should have been on SNL that would have
been a really funny skit yeah so you
have a new partner for big game parties
who is it yes I actually do and Julian
Edelman is now a part of it as well and
this is my second year teaming up with
Bounty and that's why I'm in my green
suit because I am the Bounty man yeah
and green is a great color and I'm I'm
from Buffalo so I know a thing or two
about Buffalo you know wings as well and
you got to always have blue cheese on
the side when you're from Buffalo and
you can't have football without wings
and you can't have wings without Bounty
okay I can't it gets Saucy gets messy
the quicker just comes cleans you right
up quicker picker upper I remember that
no I I agree with all of that except um
not the blue cheese I have to have
Ranch I'm and you're from
when you're from Buffalo you use blue
cheese only when you're Texan you put
Rancher ketchup on everything but when
you're from Buffalo you got to have the
buffalo blue cheese but if you're
outside of Buffalo okay I won't make the
argument yes you can have Ranch because
the buffalo blue cheese is the only
legit blue cheese I like blue cheese I
like blue cheese but there's something
about Ranch that I really love no blue
cheese really I just Ranch and I just
want I need something The Vessel for it
to wait till you have the buffalo blue
cheese okay I have had I have had
Buffalo I like it I like it and maybe
when I'm in Buffalo I'll do that yes
when you're in Buffalo everywhere else I
say no um so if you weren't if you
weren't an athlete people ask me this
about music but if you weren't an
athlete what would what do you think
you'd be doing what would I be doing
well my dad he's been in the fitness
industry for 33 years now selling
fitness equipment couple of my brothers
sell the fitness equipment for him as
well so I love to workout whole family
look this athletic you're just all yes
they all do yes so does mine they stay
fit and actually three of my brothers
played in the NFL I played with two of
them on the Patriots at at a moment too
and then the my fourth Brother played in
the minor leagues for baseball as well
so we all made pro and we all still work
out we all we're all still active and we
all still compete versus each other as
well so Health oh my God so wait there's
four boys four boys growing up four of
us yeah no five of us total my mom is an
angel oh my I just prayed for her yes
yes yes there we are oh my gosh I have
one boy in my house and it's nuts um
y'all are very um well you break a lot
of things so how did your Dad or Mom
settle fights how did because that had
to happen well at first my mom would try
to settle the fights and then she just
let it go after about five months she
goes hey I'm just going to let them go
they're going to wear each other out and
then we just had a rule in the house no
hitting in the face and no hitting where
it counts if you know what I'm talking
about so that was the only rules of the
house other than that you can beat down
the other brother as much as you
want
that's why I was so good at football I
didn't feel those hits because growing
up since one years old my brother just
pound my quas P oh yeah cuz you're the
you're not like high you're like fourth
on the list right like you're four yeah
you probably got beat up on and I was
the biggest Troublemaker by far it's
always it's always yeah it's always the
smaller ones I heard you also played
trumpet as a kid which I found random
for some reason well in fifth in fifth
grade it was mandatory to play an
instrument so we had a trumpet and all
we did was hand me downs we handed me
down sports equipment we hand me down
clothes in our family I mean I just the
amount of saliva that goes in that
trumpet only way you can get by hand me
but I mean they clean the Trump hand me
down family I get it so we would hand
down the troph uh not the trophy well
the it is a trophy kind of the trumpet's
a trophy and uh by the time it came to
me there was 50 dents in the trophy
because it wasn't just used for
instrumental class it was also used as a
weapon in the house yes your poor mother
we got to get her on the show she having
us write a book ma'am okay um Super Bowl
Super Bowl predictions do you still I
heard on The Tonight Show you said 49ers
they've been to the championship game uh
NFC Championship or Super Bowl like
literally the last five years and they
can't get that Super Bowl win so I think
this is the year for them even though
it's going to be a tough game versus the
Chiefs yeah I mean they're playing good
right now too they are but man I just I
think I always go towards it's nothing
against the Chiefs I I always like an
Underdog Story like the Lions was a
great story this season until you know
that last game but um but it was a great
story like it was it's it's like fun to
like go along with it I agree and I was
actually uh cheering for the Detroit
Lions to win it all as well so I was sad
when they lost I know yeah all right
let's do another quick break you can see
grank attempt fanduel's kick of Destiny
before the big game this Sunday go
online for details
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home